cash checks and credit cards all
dominated the world's economy for years
but they all have big downsides
first you've got to go through a
middleman and they make payments more
expensive for everyone because of their
fees
second these payments can be really
really slow
they can take days sometimes we don't
live in a world where everything shuts
down after five o'clock so why should
our money
third sending money abroad can be a
nightmare a very very very expensive
nightmare
fourth fraud can be a huge problem
counterfeit bills worth millions of
dollars are in circulation hurting
shoppers and businesses
cryptocurrencies are designed to fix
this
although bitcoin was technically the
first one invented back in 2008 projects
like digicash were exploring online
money in the 1990s
when you hand over a ten dollar bill in
a store it's impossible to spend that
same ten dollar bill somewhere else
bitcoin also prevents double spending
that's because every transaction is
verified and recorded on a blockchain
protecting the network against hacks
the network is run by thousands of
computers around the world this means
that it's always online and very
difficult to disrupt
bitcoin's blockchain can only handle a
few transactions per second and fees can
be unpredictable
but new technology like the lightning
network helps make bitcoin payments fast
and cheap
thousands of cryptocurrencies now exist
some of them are directly related to
bitcoin like bitcoin cash others have
been built from scratch including ether
and xrp
and cryptocurrencies that aren't bitcoin
are known as altcoins
in the world of wine higher prices mean
you'll normally get a better bottle
things are different in the world of
cryptocurrencies
you can buy some coins for under a cent
while others cost tens of thousands of
dollars
but don't be fooled into thinking one
cryptocurrency is better than another
based on its price
there are some important facts you need
to find out too
first there's the market capitalization
and you can calculate this
by multiplying the cryptocurrency's
price by the number of coins in
circulation
if a cryptocurrency is worth ten dollars
and has one billion coins in circulation
its market cap will be 10 billion
dollars
that's higher than a cryptocurrency
worth 20
with 100 million coins in circulation
that market cap would be just 2 billion
trading volumes are also important as
this tells you how many coins have
changed hands in the past 24 hours
a high number means the strong demand
now you may be wondering what exactly
can you do with crypto
an increasing number of shops now accept
cryptocurrencies as a payment method
in 2021 paypal launched a new feature
that allows users to buy things at
millions of merchants using bitcoin
ether litecoin or bitcoin cash
crypto credit cards have also burst onto
the scene meaning digital assets can be
spent in every place that accepts visa
or mastercard
after a payment is made the crypto is
taken out of your account and instantly
converted into cash
el salvador has also made bitcoin legal
tender making it one of the few places
in the world where starbucks pizza hut
and mcdonald's accept crypto directly
we're still at an early stage when it
comes to crypto being used by the masses
but other exciting use cases have
emerged too
decentralized finance services mean you
can now take out crypto loans
some platforms allow you to save your
coins and earn interest offering a far
better deal than old-fashioned banks
a few cryptocurrencies can also be
staked
this is where you lock up your coins and
help keep a blockchain network secure
earning new coins as a reward
cryptocurrencies can even be used to buy
things that live on blockchains like
non-fungible tokens
if you're new to cryptocurrencies you
might be wondering this
why are they so volatile
well it's partly down to the fact that
assets like bitcoin and ether are still
pretty new
some cryptocurrencies have a limit on
the maximum number of coins that will
ever exist 21 million in bitcoin's case
this lack of supply means prices can
rise when demand is high
normal currencies are also controlled by
central banks
they have a range of tools that are
designed to keep dollars pounds and
euros stable
these controls don't exist in the crypto
world resulting in much bigger price
movements on a daily basis
stable coins are another type of
cryptocurrency that has emerged in
recent years
these assets are designed to have a
constant value meaning one stablecoin
will always be worth one dollar one
pound one euro or whatever fiat currency
it's attached to
so how do you buy cryptocurrencies
well the most common place to go is a
crypto exchange
here you can convert traditional
currencies into digital assets
many trading platforms accept a range of
payment methods including bank transfers
and credit cards
some of these websites can charge high
fees so it's really worth shopping
around
if you're interested in buying altcoins
you might need to purchase a major
cryptocurrency like bitcoin ether or
teva first
and just like supermarkets don't stock
every beer in existence exchanges don't
support every single altcoin out there
because of this you might need to use
multiple exchanges
there are other ways of buying crypto
too
bitcoin atms are physical machines where
you can buy this cryptocurrency using
cash
some shops even offer bitcoin vouchers
that can later be redeemed on exchanges
both of these methods can help demystify
the world of crypto and make coins
easier to buy without technical know-how
cryptocurrencies are changing the world
and in the coming years they're set to
become a lot more common
central banks around the world are now
creating digital versions of their own
currencies
facebook wants to offer crypto to
billions of itch users too
new coins are emerging all the time and
who knows the one that ends up taking
over the world might not even exist yet
if you enjoyed this video be sure to
leave a like and a comment the